well I can tell you why I can tell you
why these attempts to shut people down
are being made because you need to know
this so as far as I've been able to
determine
this kind of protest is an expression of
a philosophy that's grounded partly in
post-modernism and partly in Marxism now
the postmodern element is basically this
there's no such thing
a genuine individual identity but the
Mises group identity and you liked it or
not only have the interests of your
group and the whole world is nothing but
a battleground between groups of
different interests there's no dialogue
there's no possibility of parking
between the groups it's just a power
stage where combat has to take place and
so the reason that speakers with home
the radical post modernists and the
Marxist don't agree or deny the platform
is because those people do not believe
from a philosophical position the
dialogue to bring consensus and all
that's left if you forego that
particular principle is this and this is
only where it starts you know the fact
is is that you're all pretty damn
civilized and thank God for that because
if there are enough Falls in the crowd
especially those who were intent on
violence this would turn out very
differently we do not want to go down
that pathway it's a big mistake we've
been down that pathway many many times
I would certainly not conform to a
consensus that was against my belief
merely because it was a consensus after
the group is wrong the question was if
there was a consensus against my beliefs
would I forego them an answer that would
be well first it would depend on what my
conscience said what are we going to do
assume that the consensus is correct the
Nazis had a consensus right the
individual has a conscience and you have
to know the group we've talked a lot in
your personality class about confronting
your shadow and shedding your shadow do
you find that people who care less about
what other people think and care more
about their conscience have integrated
their shadow maybe more than people who
care more about science or others
okay so there is a question the question
was stemming from my personality class
do I think that people are willing to
abide by their conscience are those
who've integrated their shadow and I
would say yes because you have to be a
bit of a monster to stand up to the
crowd right if you're too concerned with
people like you and if you're to avoid
them conflict then you're going to
change sign of pressure and you don't
want to do that because if you let
people stop you from moving forward you
just end up being something and if you
something to stop you've got your life
in you and that's no good
so you have to get tough but you have to
get tough in a way that's controlled
right it has to be controlled because
otherwise you're the puppet of your
worst impulses and that's a terrible
thing to be